RETO MEIER: Hello, and welcome
to "This Week in Android
Development" for
July 15, 2013.
My name is Reto Meier.
Last week we saw Ankur Kotwal
show us how to make our apps
beautiful by making them more
modern, as well as how to use
spacing in typography, while
Chet taught us how to add
curves to our motion.
Good advice, both within your
apps and in the club.
We also opened the mid-year
Android Developer Survey.
These surveys are critical for
helping us understand your
Android developer challenges
and frustrations so that we
can help you overcome them.
This year's survey is available
in Japanese and
simplified and traditional
Chinese as well as English, so
you can tell us exactly what you
think in the language of
your choice.
The [? writer ?]
team have put together an
excellent guide for efficient
data transfers using
sync adapters.
Remember, every time you use a
repeating alarm to sync data,
Sundar kills a Bugdroid.
So this is one Android training
class you should be
paying close attention to.
In terms of apps, we saw the
latest Google Maps release.
CBS Sports released an app for
fans of the NFL and another
app for every other sport.
And Trulia released an update
to their popular app, which
provides Bay Area residents with
a way to shock and alarm
their friends and families in
other states and countries.
In Android Developers Live,
the Google Play games team
talk Google Play games.
And Android Design in Action
returns with an app redesigned
from our GDG Oslo App Clinic,
which also includes a guide to
design consistency.
Last week's backstage was
delayed until this week, so
join the guys for a session
of Q&A around making apps
beautiful before checking out
the last DevByte in that
series as Ankur looks
at making your apps
beautiful on tablets.
Then on Friday, I'll be taking
a look at cricket apps in the
app clinic, just in time for
Australia to tie up the Ashes
within three days of
the second Test.
As always, you can go
to developers.googl
e.com/live/android to see what
we've got planned for ADL this
coming week.
That's all for "This Week
in Android Developers"
for July 15, 2013.
All day, all night, I've got
the lights in my eyes.